ah there we go thank you
sorry about that so yeah as Dave said my
name's Will I worked at foundation DB
way back in the ancient myths of time
and I'm now doing something a little bit
different I'm here to talk about the
future of software development what on
earth could I mean by that
well as somebody who is asked to give a
big-picture talk at a software
conference I believe I'm contractually
obligated to begin with a slide
depicting Moore's law and also my
pointer doesn't work okay there it is
Moore's law clearly you can see here
we've got years on the x-axis there and
we've got clock speed on the y-axis
right and as you can clearly see it's
going up and to the right kind of
exponentially and well hold on a second
you sure that's the did we get the right
slide is this is this the Moore's law is
that is that clock speed or is that is
that harddrive density or maybe oh my
goodness it's weaving and spinning
productivity that's I wasn't expecting
that
that's that's really weird there must
have been some kind of mix-up okay let's
let's try this again okay oh yeah here
we go
that's that's totally the Moore's Law
slide you've got that nice logarithmic
y-axis there you see that yeah that's uh
what it's steam engine efficiency what
what is going on here all right let's
let's try one more time okay
all right anybody want to guess what
this one is okay I'll give you a hint
the x-axis here is the actual years
along which Moore's Law actually did
operate now all right it's actually
industrial diamonds
so why have I wasted your time with
three different graphs all of which are
not Moore's Law the reason is I think we
in the software industry or in the
computing industry more broadly have a
little bit of a tendency to think that
were special we think there were somehow
different from every other technological
endeavor that mankind has engaged in and
something that people point out a lot is
this Moore's Law thing people say where
else in human history has there ever
been this exponential increase in the
capabilities of the underlying hardware
of what we're doing and the answer as
I'm hope I've convinced you is actually
everywhere it's incredibly incredibly
common at first and the reason is that
exponential growth is really really easy
when what you have is really really
primitive and so the fact that we
observe this Moore's Law relationship
maybe still is actually not telling us
that software is special it's telling us
that software is early right it's
telling us that we're at the beginning
that we haven't trailed off yet into a
logistic curve which is what usually
happens in technology and I actually
find this fact to be incredibly
empowering right it means it means we we
get the chance to be pioneers too it
means those guys in the 60s and the 70s
didn't have all the fun it means there's
a lot more to do and I think one
implication of this is it also means
that we should be looking for the
possibilities of radical transformations
in software engineering right things
that will completely change how what it
means to be a software engineer what it
means to write programs there's a couple
reasons for this one is because we're
early in history and so therefore
there's still low-hanging fruit
another is that we're early in history
and what that means is that the vast
majority of software is not written yet
it's can be written in the future which
means that if we make process
improvements now they have a very long
time horizon over which they can pay off
I think both of those facts argue in
favor of us taking a really serious and
hard look Andrea
amening what it is we do and so that's
meaning behind the title of my talk the
future of software engineering I think
the future is out there in front of us
we're not there yet but maybe maybe we
will help create it ok so right so the
future there's a lot of different
possible radical transformations I could
talk about right I could talk about new
programming languages and how something
from category theory is gonna totally
change how everybody does everything
might be true that would be a radical
transformation if it worked or I could
talk about the sociology and economics
of software how who becomes a software
engineer might be changing drastically
that could be a radical transformation
of the software industry but I'm talking
not going to talk about either of those
things instead I'm gonna talk about
testing yeah right because why because
if you want to look for the potential
for radical transformations one way of
doing that one pretty good heuristic is
to look at where things are currently
the most absolutely awful and terrible
and painstaking and brutal and I think
testing kind of qualifies right I saw a
report from some analysts it was like
Gartner forced or somebody they
estimated that 30% of all effort in
software development was spent on
testing or on QA more broadly and if
you're like me you hear that number and
you're like 30% that's way way way too
low right well I guess like you add
together the amount of time you spend
writing tests the amount of time you
spend fixing the bugs that your tests
turn up the amount of time you spend
fixing the bugs your tests don't turn up
the amount of time you spend working
around and dealing with and mitigating
all the bugs in the layers below you
that they haven't fixed those jerks
all the time and effort that goes into
dealing with the fallout of inadequate
testing the outages the economic damage
right like that's like we're talking at
least 50% of my time and I don't think
I'm extremely unusual and you multiply
that by a lot of software engineers
the world we are talking about trillions
and trillions of dollars of productivity
going into this if you could take that
and you could eliminate it or make it
much more efficient much smaller
fraction of what we do that would be a
radical transformation of the software
industry and so the reason that I'm
giving this talk at this particular
conference is as I think people are
generally aware foundation DB had a
different relationship with testing than
many products did testing for us was not
an ordeal it did not suck up in vast
quantities of developer energy so I'm
not actually gonna dive into this a
whole lot both because I think a lot of
people here already know how foundation
DB did testing Evan and Ben both covered
it and sort of gave you some information
about it instead what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna try and take what we did at F
DB and recontextualize it I'm gonna try
and give you a different perspective on
it situate it as one technique within a
much broader class of approaches and you
know talk about why you should be using
them talk about why you might not be
using them talk about why no really you
actually should be using them and if I
have time then I will close with like
some slightly more speculative stuff
okay but before I get to all that let's
first talk about why testing is so
miserable right now one reason that I
think a lot of people are very familiar
with is that your tests are usually
non-deterministic right as soon as your
test relies on any kind of external
service or as soon as you run it in a
even slightly noisy environment suddenly
it fails one out of every hundred times
or one out of every 10,000 times
either way it's a nightmare it's a
maintainability nightmare
it's a nightmare when you actually go to
try and debug something you don't have
confidence as to whether you've actually
fixed it or not if the test does fail
you're awfully tempted to say well
that's that's a known flaky test right
you ignore it and then it turns out no
actually it really wasn't
problem um I think people are also
generally familiar with the way that the
foundation DB team made heroic efforts
to clawback this property in our testing
using a technique called deterministic
simulation Evan touched on that briefly
there's tons of material online about it
as Dave said I gave a talk about it
years ago you can go read about that so
I'm not gonna talk about it but all that
said I think we in this room should be
aware that most of the world does not
have this right most of the world is
still in the dark ages can't do this and
it's an ongoing source of pain and
suffering and it's really bad okay but
there are more reasons that testing is
terrible another reason testing is
terrible is that your tests are very
very often fragile what do I mean by
that I mean that your test comes to rely
on properties of your system that are
incidental in some way that are not the
ones that you thought you were testing
so a really simple example of this is
suppose you're trying to test a computer
game all right like a 2d platforming
game one way you might do that is by
recording an input right so you say if I
hold down the right arrow for 6.7
seconds and then I hit the jump key for
3.2 seconds and then I shoot the bad guy
you know assert that bla happens and
that's a great test until you change
literally anything at all about your
program right you change the level
layout you change the physics engine
you've changed the input sampling rate
you run that test on a different
computer it's probably going to fail
this is not like some weirdness about
testing computer games either this
happens in all kinds of testing domains
it happens in UI testing frequently it
happens in distributed systems testing
right like imagine you're trying to like
play forward some series of events and
something changes towards the beginning
right the two tests histories are gonna
diverge and you're gonna be off testing
some totally different thing than you
thought you were right so this is a
really bad problem like like the flaky
problem it's a maintainability nightmare
like the flaky problem you're very very
tempted to ignore the test because of
this I heard about a post-mortem
recently
of some giant outage at some giant
company that his name I shall not
mention we're literally the same
check-in that caused the bug that caused
the giant outage also disabled the test
that would have told them that they were
about to have a giant outage why because
everybody knew that test breaks every
time you check something in so like of
course right
that's really bad an even more insidious
failure mode for this by the way is
sometimes your test can fail open in the
sense that you make some change your
test continues to pass but it's now
passing for a totally different reason
than you thought it was passing right
and so now it's a source of false
confidence and you yeah it's it's really
really bad and I don't think people have
a great answer to this problem
okay but there's there's an even worse
one which is even if you somehow make
your test neither flaky nor fragile it's
probably not testing the right stuff I
think there's actually a really like a
deep reason behind this almost like an
analytic proof okay so it goes something
like this the reason that people write
tests is because human beings are
astonishingly bad at thinking through
all the possible branches of control
flow that a program could take right
we're astonishingly bad at thinking
through all the possible orders in which
two threads could interleave or some
other asynchronous construct could
interleaf we're astonishingly bad at
thinking through all the possible points
in the execution of a distributed
algorithm we're a failure might occur
and what form that failure might take
but that very fact right that's why we
need tests but that very fact means that
we're unable to write tests to cover all
the things that we actually need to
cover right like because if we could if
we were smart enough or had the right
kind of brains
to write all the tests we needed to
write then we would have just written
the code correctly in the first place
right and so I think this is like really
scary and really true and the
implication is that tests can be useful
for turning up regressions but almost
completely useless for telling you about
unknown unknowns
that's that's bad right the latter is I
think the more important problem it's
certainly the harder problem and people
try and fight against this in a bunch of
different ways people people try and use
coverage metrics to fight against this
which i think is a nice idea but
ultimately kind of useless to like you
know your distributed systems people
imagine that you have a distributed
system and you're a test suite gives you
100% branch coverage on it are you sure
your system has no bugs no obviously not
right you could have a bug that depended
on whether some code executed on process
a before or after it executes on process
B you'd have 100% branch coverage either
way this is not like a distributed
systems thing either right like imagine
you were writing a Python interpreter
and you get 100% branch coverage have
you tested all the interesting behavior
in that Python interpreter no Python is
a turing-complete language there's an
infinite mountain of interesting
behavior that you could continue to
exercise so branch coverage is a nice
idea but it doesn't actually solve this
problem at all um okay I actually think
that all of these problems are just
symptoms of a deeper underlying problem
the real problem and the real problem is
that testing is still totally manual
right what we call automated testing is
not automated in the slightest we've
automated the absolute dumbest part of
it which is executing the tests running
them automated testing to most people
means having Jenkins run your tests and
you know that's that's nice
that's certainly better than not doing
that right having to sitting there and
like typing who does that actually tons
of industries do that so you know good
good start but still we have every one
of those tests is painstakingly manually
constructed by a human being in the
first place imagine if this were any
other industry right imagine if I told
you that there's an industry out there
where you know scads of highly paid
intelligent people are sitting doing
mind-numbing rote repetitive predictable
tasks with with no automation right what
would you say what
your VC say they would say that's an
industry that's ripe for disruption and
you know welcome ladies and gentlemen to
software engineering right for a
disruption and I think this is the real
secret sauce behind what foundation DB
did it's not so much just the
deterministic simulation although that
was a very important part of it it was
that we didn't go down this path
it's that whenever we had a new piece of
functionality we didn't say how can I
write some tests to cover this it was
more like how can I write a system that
will forever be generating new and
interesting tests that will exercise
this that's like it's a different it's a
shift of mindset it's a shift of
philosophy and it's such a big change
that I think it needs a new name and so
for the rest of this talk I'm gonna talk
about automated creation of tests in
addition to merely automated execution
of tests as autonomous testing which i
think is a is a better word for this
stuff and foundation DB is not like
totally special right if you know where
to look if you squint at the industry
you can see glimmerings of autonomous
testing everywhere actually a really
simple example is just fuzzing suppose
you're writing a parser that's parsing
some untrusted bytes from the network do
you sit there and say well I better
write some unit tests for this know like
if that's all you do your parser sucks I
assure you it's wrong like what you do
is you get a fuzzer to feed millions and
millions and millions of random strings
have been put into it and see if any of
them cause it to crash
that's autonomous testing it's a
primitive form of autonomous testing
property based testing is an example
from a totally different side of the
software industry right this is signing
the functional programming people came
up with it's something that the Haskell
people I think came up with the idea
here is if you have a piece of your
program or a data structure or something
with a very easy to specify interface
what you can do is construct a
specification of its contract and its
guarantees and then you tell the
computer to sit there and try and come
up with counter examples to that
contract this is a form of autonomous
testing this is actually something that
was exhaustively used in the testing of
the foundation DB document layer which
as you heard was just open source Thank
You Apple right so like the like it's
not like it foundation DB we just had
one magical tool the simulation stuff
and we like hit everything with it it's
that everybody every engineer was
constantly there was a culture of
constantly thinking about how to take
testing problems and make them less
human involved and so the question that
I've been grappling with in my career
since leaving foundation DB is why
doesn't everybody do this all the time
right because I've seen how good things
are when you do it this way and I've
also seen but I'm prohibited by NDA from
telling you about how bad things can get
when you don't do it this way the answer
is really bad by the way so like so
serious like why isn't everybody in the
universe using this stuff it's like it's
a real conundrum and it turns out that
there are actually some really really
good reasons why people don't do this
stuff but before I tell you about the
good reasons I'm gonna tell you about a
really bad reason which is I hear this
with surprising regularity that the
turing halting theorem proves that
software can never test software yeah
that's right
and you know it's it's it's kind of true
you can come to me and be like will if
your program can find bugs then surely I
can write a program which will crash if
and only if the Riemann hypothesis is
true and then in order to tell me if it
has a bug your program has to solve all
of math are you saying you can do that
and like you know fine like that's
that's true that that's correct but to
me this has a little bit of the feel of
people who say that the cap theorem
means you can't write a good distributed
database right it's like it's like kind
of an almost trivial impossibility
result which nevertheless doesn't
actually address the issue right humans
debug software humans are not mystical
Turing Oracle's like if humans can do it
then so can computers we just and we
don't need to be perfect right we
need to find every single bug in every
single program that could ever be
written which indeed the turing theorem
says you can't do all we have to do is
be better than humans or faster than
humans or more scalable than humans or
you know different from humans so I
think I think this is a dumb objection
that said I think it's actually really
closely tied to a smart objection
same as maybe arguably true of the cap
theorem and the smart objection that
this is tied to is that it's insanely
difficult and that I think is true an
easy way to sort of think about how
difficult it is is just to imagine the
size of the space you're trying to
explore right so when you're trying to
find a bug in a program you are
implicitly trying to explore the space
of all possible execution histories your
program could have the size of that
space is 256 raised to the power of the
number of bytes of input your program
has ever received that is a mind
bogglingly large space that is
inconceivably vast right you could you
could stumble around in some tiny stupid
corner of that space for the entire
lifetime of the universe and never find
anything
and yet I'm up here saying that you can
hit most of the interesting parts of
that space in a very small amount of
time how on earth can we do that the
answer is that's insanely insanely hard
and it's a challenge that people trying
to use autonomous testing I think
frequently like get shipwrecked on a
foundation DB we put an insane amount of
effort I should really say Evan put an
insane amount of effort into into
fighting this exact problem right
tweaking and tuning all the knobs bugga
fiying things to turn up bugs more often
tweaking the random number generators so
that you have processes crashing just
often enough to turn up interesting
behavior but not so often that you never
make any progress this is a this is a
really hard thing to do it takes
somebody with deep knowledge of the
system to do it it it's like it's really
draining and tough work and if you get
it wrong the failure mode is your test
say everything's good
that's a really really scary failure
mode right you need some kind of side
channel to tell you that no actually
everything is not good
hopefully that side channel is not your
customers so so I think that's super
scary the next thing is like also super
super scary and I think it's probably an
even bigger barrier to adoption so all
of the autonomous testing techniques I
listed and other ones besides which I
haven't listed all depend in some way
they're a little different but in some
way they all depend on your software
being in the right form for them to test
them and you can think of the whole
foundation DB deterministic simulation
system as having the job of wrangling a
big hairy stateful distributed system
into that form right like taking it and
turning it into a box that took an input
which was a random seed like pretending
it was a pure function so that we could
do that kind of thing
the only reason that wasn't a complete
and utter debacle was that foundation DB
was constructed with tremendous
tremendous foresight to enable that most
people can't do that I mean start with
the fact that most people aren't writing
software from scratch right most people
are working on some ginormous Java
monstrosity from the 1990s even the
people though who are writing something
from scratch rarely have the foresight
to say oh we're gonna write a
distributed database first we're gonna
spend a year writing a simulator like
who does that that takes that takes a
special kind of person to do that like
and you know a lot of people even if
they did have the inclination to do that
just wouldn't have the time right they
they need code now not in a year not in
two years so I think this is this is
like a huge huge problem and so long as
it's almost impossible to apply these
techniques after the fact it's gonna
greatly limit their their use okay and
the last thing here is what I'm calling
test Oracle's which is just a fancy way
of saying that you're you know even if
your test like turns up all the bugs in
the world it's useless if it doesn't
know when to alert you that it's found a
bug depending on the domain this can be
either really really challenging or
really really
easy if you only care that your program
doesn't crash good good news it's pretty
easy to tell when a program is crashed
it's pretty easy as hell when it's run
out of memory it's pretty easy to tell
when an assert has fired say but suppose
you were working on a graphical
application you know suppose that bugs
come in the form this border was five
pixels too far to the right or the bug
is the screen turned purple right you
might need a much more sophisticated
system to tell you when you've actually
found a bug
this happened with foundation db2 there
were a database invariants acid
invariants which were too complex to
check with a simple assert statement and
so what we had to do was design entire
workloads dedicated to setting up those
invariants and then checking that they
were true still at the end so again
depending on your domain that can be
that can be a real challenge okay but
despite all that you should all still be
using these techniques and you should
this is this is what you should be doing
there's a bunch of reasons some obvious
some not so obvious so first and most
obviously computers are cheaper than
people you might have heard this there
especially cheaper than software
engineers in the San Francisco Bay Area
so when you have computers writing your
tests instead of people writing your
tests you can write many many many more
tests and you will get a whole lot more
testing done and that will probably be
good almost more important than that
though is not just that you're gonna do
more testing it's that you're gonna do
different testing sometimes when I talk
about this stuff people ask me will are
you saying that I should like throw away
my my my lovingly crafted test suite and
just use your crazy computer thing no
don't do that
right keep keep your test suite that
will find certain kinds of bugs and the
computers will find other kinds of bugs
because computers and humans like human
like weren't yeah we're all you know
unique and special snowflakes and
different and that's wonderful but we're
all humans a computer is a total alien
all that stuff I said before about stuff
humans are bad at thinking about
computers are really good at thinking
about that stuff right so humans will
find some bugs computers will find
others and this like beautiful synthesis
of
machine will come together and it's just
it's awesome
another cool thing about computers is
you can turn them on and off very easily
in fact I hear that you can even go to
Amazon and ask for a computer for a
limited amount of time and they will
turn it on and off for you
this is this is really great this is
again something that's a little bit
different from human beings if you want
to hire more test engineers or more
software engineers that takes time you
cannot hire and fire them
instantaneously they take time to be
trained they have to sleep they have to
eat it's so annoying
computers are not like that if you want
to do a medium amount of testing or a
small amount of testing all the time and
then a really really really large amount
of testing all at once you can do that
very easily using autonomous testing
that said despite that I actually think
that that's not as important as people
think it is because I think that most of
you should be doing way more testing all
the time than you think you should be
doing and the reason has to do with the
last of these reasons here which I think
might be the most subtle which is
latency and by that I don't mean the
latency to running a single test I mean
the latency to running enough tests that
you find a single bug the reason is that
the amount of effort it takes to fix a
bug is extremely strongly tied to how
long it's been since that bug was caused
I think we all get this intuitively but
just to hammer the point home right two
situations one of them you know you're
writing some code and you go hit submit
to your repo and some pre submit hook
runs and it says blah like you haven't
you have a book you can't submit that
right now that's great that's so awesome
you have all the state of the problems
still in your head you have a literal
diff in front of you right you know
probably the bug is in one of those
lines of code this is about your best
possible case for finding and fixing
that bug compared to situation number
two where your friend causes a bug and
it slips through your testing and then
it slips through your release testing
and into a release and then some time
goes by and slips into your next
and then six more months go by and your
friend quits and then four more years go
by and you're on call and your largest
production customer calls you in the
middle of the night and says hey
something's not working what what what
do you do I mean like you're doomed
right like it's it's gonna be so bad
even if that were literally the same bug
right the amount of effort that will go
into even determining if there was a bug
in the second case is going to be orders
of magnitude larger than it would have
been to just fix it in the first place
but the good news about testing or at
least about autonomous testing is it's
an embarrassingly parallel problem you
can get a million CPU seconds of testing
done in one second or five seconds um
does law you know by running it on a
million different CPU cores that's
really cool it means if you're willing
to spend the money you can drive down
the latency between causing bugs and
fixing bugs and that is going to repay
you in money and productivity and
frustration and everything so fast it's
going to change your life it's going to
change it's it's gonna qualitatively
change the kinds of things your team can
do yeah okay so I'm gonna wrap up now
I'm running out of time and I want to
wrap up by returning to that question I
raised before which is why don't we have
computers test all our software I mean I
know I told you the reasons right there
there were a ton of like really terrible
reasons but but seriously what would it
take what would it take to change that
like how how can we bring about the kind
of epochal transformation analogous to
the invention of the compiler where only
in really weird or exceptional
situations do you go back to doing it
the old way and the answer is I don't
actually know the answer to that
question but I'm currently trying to
figure it out so Dave share over there
and I have recently started a company
and our goal is to try and figure out
the answer to this question and then
thereby making Auton
testing super-easy thereby making it
Universal thereby radically transforming
the software industry thereby assuring
in a new golden age of peace and
prosperity for all mankind it's it's
pretty early days yet it's really early
days but we have a vision and we have a
technical roadmap that we think you know
has a decent chance of getting us there
okay so there's a bunch of different you
know I would love to talk to you if
you're interested in any of the stuff
I've talked about here today there's two
kinds of people I'm especially
interested in talking to those would be
people who might be interested in coming
to work with us and people who might be
good early customers you know the latter
being like people who have really scary
QA problems that they feel like they
don't have a handle on and they think
some of these techniques could maybe
help because we have a prototype that
might kind of work but that said like
I'm also just interested in talking to
anybody who's into this stuff because
this is still a really small niche world
and not a lot of people think about this
stuff and so if you do I would love to
meet you and I am definitely over time
so I won't take questions thank you
[Applause]